- 60 second club.
- [Jewell] 60 second club.
- Making dreams happen.
- [Jewell] It is blowing up.
It is amazing.
- You know, it's
getting back on the upswing.
I took it away for a little bit,
for five minutes,
because I wanted depth,
but I realized
the depth of comments
didn't offset the
excitement of that quick minute
and just the action,
so, I brought it back
and I'm getting
real serious about it.
- [Jewell] When you did
that I was actually amazed.
I'm like, this guy
knows how to direct attention.
I was like, it's crazy.
- It's day training attention.
- [Jewell] That's crazy stuff.
- Cool, what
can I help you with?
- [Jewell] So, gosh, a lot
of different things.
So, basically
right now I am in Dallas,
I'm in the mortgage industry.
Like I said, I
was a loan officer,
so it really plays
on my natural abilities.
- Yep.
- [Jewell] I'm 26,
I've moved 21 times.
- Really?
- [Jewell] Yeah, from
California originally,
lived everywhere in California,
lived all over the place,
Atlanta, Dallas now.
- Family dynamics
or military or?
- [Jewell] I come
from a military family,
but that's not why. (laughs)
My mom was in real estate
and stuff when I was younger,
and so, we just moved
with that, and then it--
- Flipping, building?
- [Jewell] Yeah, it
just became habitual.
So, I really got sucked into it,
just that change of pace.
So, there's a lot of
positives that come outta that.
- Yeah, I mean, sure.
- So, I've never met a stranger.
I can go anywhere
and you can drop me in,
and I'll fit in pretty quickly.
But at the same time,
I haven't really developed
those long term
relationships or anything.
- Yeah, of course,
flag in the ground.
- [Jewell] Exactly.
So, I love trying new things,
and I will give my
attention to it 100%
like right in the moment.
And I will kind of dissect it,
how I will put my
brain power into it,
and then I kind of
move on to the next thing.
Because it's like,
okay, something new,
squirrel, almost in a sense.
- I think I'm like that
but what I think
has made me successful
is I've always
had one big pillar.
It's kind of
like eating a burger
but always having
different complements to it.
I think a lot of people just eat
the potato or the pickle,
or the onion,
or the mayonnaise, or
the mayonnaise and mayo,
or the ketchup, or the jalapeno,
but they never eat the burger.
- [Jewell] Right.
- Like, I have the
burger, Wine Library,
VaynerMedia,
my personal brand, investing.
Those are my burgers
but I do a million things.
Do you how many
people think this,
I mean, he's
covering me for this,
this is insane.
I have no time.
- [Jewell] Yeah, exactly.
- For me to be
spending 49 minutes on this
is so fucking crazy,
it makes zero sense.
But it sits in the
GaryVee brand pillar.
I believe in it.
But it is me being ADD'd out.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- And what I think
you need to figure out
is you gotta create
at least one burger.
I've got four, right?
You need to have one.
- [Jewell] Right.
- If you feel you
don't, I don't know yet,
but that's the analogy.
- [Jewell] Yeah, so I would say
I don't necessarily
have a burger.
- Right. Because what the
burger does is it allows you
to create the wealth creation
or the financial stability
that allows you to go flirt.
- [Jewell] Yeah, this is true.
Yeah, it gives you freedom
to have that flexibility.
One thing I'm
trying to do on the side,
so, I'm learning this whole
business development thing
and trying to play on that
just because of the
relationship aspect.
- Before we go there,
let's work backwards.
At this moment of your life,
what are the major KPIs?
Like, you know,
if you go real long term,
of course, right now
there's gonna be a lot of things
like that money stream and
different things of that nature.
But like, if you can anticipate
good things playing out
or not good things,
how do you see it?
How big is your ambition?
And not like peacocking,
like, you're still a young man
but you're not 14, either.
What's your intuition say?
Because this is
a big part of it.
- [Jewell] Yeah, absolutely.
So, I think, I mean,
money's important.
- Of course.
- [Jewell] But it's not a
driving factor in any capacity.
So, one thing that I love to do,
and I know you hear
this day in and day out,
but I love to give back.
So, I'm 26, by about no
means, no shit. (laughs)
Like I'm still
definitely learning.
But there's a
lot of opportunities
that I've been afforded that
a lot of people can't have.
And so, my big thing
that I kind of operate
from my personal space is
every conversation
that I have with somebody
if I can give them
something that, you know,
basically in the
same way that you do.
You give
somebody practical stuff,
I just try and share that.
- Is that because
you love being a leader
and deploying your charisma?
- [Jewell] So, I'm
the oldest of four boys.
- Makes sense.
- [Jewell] And then
also just being that mover.
- Yeah, I get it.
- [Jewell] I have to kind of--
- So, you get a high
from that leadership role.
- [Jewell]
Absolutely, absolutely.
- I get it.
- [Jewell] And so,
what that means in terms of
a business space or a
professional space or career,
I mean, you can kind of dig
that anywhere that you want.
So, one thing that I'm
doing on the side right now
I'm just gonna see
how it kind of flourishes,
I'm actually gonna start a blog.
- You should definitely do that.
That was the next
place that I was gonna go,
which is do you feel like
you wanna be a personality?
- [Jewell] I mean,
yeah, I can be.
- And I know you know
enough about my thing,
and I'm not going down the
who the fuck do
you think you are,
don't be that
26-year-old life coach.
But I do think we've
never lived in a time
where people can
be personal brands,
I mean, it's
really funny, right.
I wrote a book almost a
decade ago called "Crush It!",
which is go build
your personal brand.
And then I've
spent the last 10 years
making fun of people who--
- [Jewell] Who do it.
- Because so many
people try to fake it.
- [Jewell] Yeah. No, absolutely.
- And that's how I got
to document over creating.
- [Jewell] Man,
I can't tell you.
I mean, obviously,
that's gone viral
but that's so huge,
just that concept.
- Because then you don't have
to fake it till you make it.
- [Jewell] Exactly.
- To me, you're
not any different,
outside of a couple
tweaks here and there,
like me 26 years old
was gonna be me, this.
I wish I was
documenting that shit.
I wish I was going
through my first bit.
- [Jewell] The ability to do it,
I mean, that requires video--
- So devastated that
shit's lost in history.
Again, just vibing
off your natural charisma
and the whole thing,
that's the game.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- You need to figure that out.
- [Jewell] Yeah, absolutely.
And so my thought
process behind the blog
is, obviously, I
wanna give value to people.
- And you're
gonna do a blog written?
- [Jewell] It will be written.
- 'Cause you can write?
I can write but I
also have a lot of videos,
obviously, a big piece,
I think that's easy.
Podcasts add an element to that,
kind of like an
interview type thing.
I think there's a
lot of different factors.
- So, let me give
you something to debate.
I think nobody has taken my
words and gone real practical.
Like, I think
somebody should brand,
I think you should call
it like The Journey to 42.
Somebody needs to put some
context around what I'm doing.
26, right?
- [Jewell] Yep.
- The 20-Year Itch, like
I think you should write,
everything you should talk about
is to getting to 46 years old.
Like nobody's
synthesized down my thesis
and made it about that.
- [Jewell] Right.
Like, you know?
- [Jewell] Absolutely.
I think with your
document versus create,
so I, habitually I'm a little,
I have that kind of ADD
in terms of change and things,
but I'm also a perfectionist.
So, I love things
to be really sweet.
And so, before I heard
the document versus create
I was very much involved in the
this has to be perfect,
I wanna do it right.
- Document versus
create was built
out of my internal
hate for perfection.
- [Jewell] Yep.
And I realize that it
doesn't get me anywhere
when I try and be perfect.
- It doesn't exist,
it's a subjective call.
What the fuck is perfect?
- [Jewell] Exactly.
So, once I heard that
I got much more into my
SnapChat, and my Instagram,
my Facebook and documenting,
and now I'm much more--
- Well, go figure.
- [Jewell] I know,
it's ironic how it works.
- Go Figure.
- [Jewell] So, it's pushed me
into more of a creative space
where now I'm not so much--
- What I don't
think people realize is
by documenting and
communicating on a daily basis,
as you build an
audience that is just interested
in people, reality TV at scale,
it opens up business
development opportunities.
You never know when
you're gonna write something
or say something in a
video six years from now
that unlocks the
leader that wants to see you.
I had one of the great
stars of the last 20 years
team in here a couple hours ago,
they came to me off the
document thing and creating.
I think, again, as you
know, you've seen this.
- [Jewell] Yeah, absolutely
- I've had these
specific meetings.
Everybody gives
slightly different advice.
I do think,
I think people don't know
if I'm just being nice.
Like remembering you
from the DC event is easy
because you have a
little bit of a presence.
- [Jewell] Thank you.
- I think you need
to figure that out.
And what I mean by that is
I actually think you
have a very basic blueprint.
I think you need to
communicate on a daily basis.
Don't bullshit.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- But I do think a child
of 21 locations in 26 years,
a oldest of four boys,
I think opening up,
and you haven't
opened up yet to me
on what that 21, you know,
that 21 locations has
some dirt in there, too.
- [Jewell] It absolutely does.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
- Of course.
I think you need
to find your cadence.
I didn't open up about things.
I didn't talk
about my struggles until,
it took me time.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- I think, so,
I buy into a 26 year old
that's never built
a $10 million business
from a "leadership" standpoint,
'cause I buy into
being the oldest of four,
especially if you can
give me a story or two.
- [Jewell] Right. Yeah.
- You know?
So, I think you should
definitely go hardcore at that.
I'll say another thing,
and this is as much for you
as everybody who's
watching 'cause I think
this is a new thought I have.
I think there's
a lot of DRocks.
I think a lot of
people see DRock,
and they know I pay
him, and they're like,
"Well, shit, I can't do
that, I have to do this."
I actually don't
think that's true.
I actually think there
are thousands of people
that are watching
this right now,
and even if you didn't
have the serendipity and luck
of being here, and now
it'll naturally come to you
in the comments of
DailyVee, you're gonna get this,
I think there's just, if I
were you, and more importantly
the 10,000 people
watching right now,
for this advice,
they should go to YouTube,
they should spend a
month, find 59, 159,
437 people making video content,
who have very few subscriptions,
DRock could have been had.
Somebody could have
emailed him and said,
"I believe in your talent,
come and be my partner.
"Come and document me,
I'm going to be like that.
"Believe in me."
I think you can
sell people on that.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
I would believe you,
let alone 500 people
who just want to be artists
and who just want to do it,
and who want to be
nomads too, so that's
another thing to
think about, man.
- [Jewell] Okay, and so I think,
on that note specifically,
given the fact that with
cell phones and all that,
we have the ability
to do it all ourselves,
I don't know if necessarily
that's something like,
me going and finding out--
- That's up to you.
- [Jewell] Now, that could
be beneficial in the future.
And it could be
teaming up or something,
it's not
necessarily hiring them,
it's somebody that
just wants to jump in.
- It's number two.
If you can't afford it,
I just generally,
you have to understand:
it's a supply and demand game.
- [Jewell] Right.
When people get mad
about "working for free,"
they don't understand
it's all supply and demand.
No hardcore
amazing computer developer
works for free anymore
because there's demand.
- [Jewell] Right.
When there are
unlimited kids filming,
and listen, if
you're Steven Spielberg, go!
But before you're that,
where do you think,
you know it's so funny,
"working for free."
Working for free on your terms,
versus getting paid
dick to pay your dues
on not terms,
it's not even close!
- [Jewell] Yeah, it's true.
You're enjoying it,
it's a passion.
- Yeah, get in here.
I've been waiting for this.
I've been waiting for this!
Is that going to
fit there, though?
No, I don't think so.
That's why I wanted
it to go up and down.
But we might be able to hack it.
- [Jewell] Yeah
because that one
could probably fit on that wall.
- Yeah, so you know
what we're going to do?
We're going to
move that up there,
That right there,
and that right there.
- [Jewell] That's badass.
Got it? Book, thing right there,
because it looks
thin enough, right?
The top one?
You're going to
move family business
to where the book thing
is, and that right there.
- [Man] Perfect.
- Alright, cool,
just put it right there.
Yeeeeeaaaahh, I'm
pumped about that.
I'm always
trying to reference it,
and then I'm like,
"fuck, where are the books?"
- [Jewell] So I
think that's absolutely,
that is so funny, with--
- The biggest thing
you have to get over
is having a dude or chick
following you around on camera.
Because that's douchey.
And I'm the most egotistical,
and self-promoter,
and it took me a couple months.
- [Jewell] So that's
a big thing
that I think was
kind of a mental block is,
man I'm going to
look like a douche
filming myself all day long.
- Everybody looks like a douche
when they start something new.
Hollywood made fun of reality TV
like nobody's fucking business.
Hollywood made
fun of the Kardashians
like nobody's business.
Everbody's a douche
until they're a pioneer.
- [Jewell] And it's cool.
In that, I've gotten
through that mental block,
because now I'm more
comfortable in front of it.
I can kind of be open,
and so if you're talking about
sharing those stories so much,
That's why
I think the the blog's
going to be great,
if I can do that.
- As long as you
don't bullshit it.
People that are
trying to sell $5,000,
I literally had a
guy email me and said,
"Hey Gary, I need you to help
me, teach me social media."
And there was
something in the way he asked,
I don't remember
the second part,
but he basically said,
"for my social media firm."
That's what it
was, right DRock?
So I emailed him
back and I was like,
"Hold on, are you charging
people to sell to social media?"
And he's like,
"Yeah," and I'm like,
"And you don't
know anything about it?"
He's like, "Yeah,"
and he didn't get it.
(group laughter)
And it scared
the shit out of me,
and I know why it's happening,
but all you have to
do is tell the truth.
- [Jewell] And that's my thing--
And again, I'm
giving you, and again,
you know this isn't normally
the way I push this hard.
It's because I actually
think you have charisma.
- [Jewell] Thank you.
And I actually
think you're starting to
give me some data,
right, like 21, 26,
you're going to
have to dig into that.
Oldest of four, you
- [Jewell] And I
think, so, I've been very--
- And remind people.
You know one thing, and
I'm sorry to cut you off
but I want to give you this:
I think the best thing I do,
and I don't get to do it often
'cause I keep myself in a lane,
once in a blue moon
people ask me questions in a Q&A
that are outside of
marketing and business,
and I always say,
"I don't know."
- [Jewell] Yeah.
And it's amazing,
I actually wish more people,
I feel like I'm going to start
planting people in my Q&As
to ask me something
about science, or healthcare,
just so I can say I don't know,
'cause watch all the faces
when you peacock the way I do,
and then you come
all the way the other way
and go, "I actually
don't know that world."
- [Jewell] Right.
(blows air) It's the
greatest move,
I wish it happened more often.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
And I think you can do that.
- [Jewell] It provides no
value if you bullshit people.
- But everybody's doing it.
And unfortunately,
we're in a world right now
where it's on the offense,
because in a world of fake news,
and fake data,
what I'm more fearful of
is if the truth
loses its place in society,
then everything,
all bets are off.
And so, I think I've
over-indexed it.
I get extremely upset
when people compare me
to other people that
they think are like me
just because of energy,
or are in your face.
You've just got
to have your truth,
so focus on that.
- [Jewell] And I think
one thing maybe I'll ask,
and I know it's
different for every person.
I'm very IQ oriented.
- You are?
- [Jewell] For architecture,
that's just how my brain works.
- That's great.
- [Jewell] I've
got that perfectionist thing
going on, I think.
- That's good.
- [Jewell] So,
I feel like I'm
one of the most
emotional people that I know,
but I don't, like it's so--
- You don't show it.
- [Jewell] It's so closed off--
- Because you protect it?
- [Jewell] I honestly
couldn't tell you.
I think it is, because I'm--
- Of course.
Do you feel like it's a cliche,
'cause you're a man
and you had to be the man,
the oldest brother?
- [Jewell] I think
a little bit of it
probably came from
being the oldest brother,
and like, look,
I've got to be tough,
and I think a
little bit of it predicates
itself on the
logical, like, look man,
nobody's going to care
about my feelings anyway.
It's like I've got
to figure out how to...
- I don't know,
I'm EQ'd out for days,
and I'm under IQ in my opinion,
and I talk about nobody cares
about your feelings either.
So, I think the
thing, that most,
so, here's
something interesting.
You got me into a good place.
I think most
people fear my blueprint,
which is, I talk in a
lot of contradictions,
because they're true,
and I think people are scared
to be
pigeonholed within a micro.
- [Jewell] Hmmm. Yeah.
And I feel the
negative effects of it.
People have reactions
to me in both pro and con
for that reason.
I've got an answer
for you, it's similar
to document and create:
let it play out.
Let it play out!
Nobody's going to
think you're irrational
if you're rational
in a 50 year window.
Nobody's going to think
I'm a snake oil salesman
when it's all said and done.
They did, they may, they could
still believe it right now
because they're
waiting for this, like this,
inevitable shoe
that's going to drop.
That I'm going to
close all my content down,
or I've been actually
quietly taking five dollars
from you each
month from your Venmo.
Cynicism exists.
- [Jewell] Oh yeah.
- But the thing
that always beats cynicism
is the truth at
the end of the game.
- [Jewell] Yeah and obviously
you're super long term.
- But that's it, man.
- [Jewell] It's all long term?
- It's all long term.
- [Jewell] I think the
challenge--
- Is within the short term?
Well, what do you
need in the short term?
Because if you
care about short term,
it means you need something.
So the thing that
always drove me was,
I didn't need anything.
One great thing is,
because I didn't need to show,
my self confidence
was so within,
the thing I didn't need
that so many of my friends
needed in their 20s
was things to put them on
to girls, to the world,
they needed a BMW.
They needed a watch.
They needed to go to
Vegas and have table service.
I didn't need those things,
which saved me a lot of money,
which meant I didn't need money.
- [Jewell] Right. Yeah, no.
Makes a lot of sense.
And especially, the 26-year-old
world that I live in
(Gary blows lips)
that's crazy.
And being in Dallas, you know,
it's a tough place to live.
- You're right.
- Even if you go
outdoors to do anything,
all you can do
is eat, shop, drink, party.
- And Dallas is
one of those places
where the dollars
and the perception
lead to fun stuff.
- [Jewell] Exactly, exactly.
I get it.
I'm empathetic to that.
Look, this is
where it gets fun.
This is where I get to say
the things I love the most,
which is okay,
and that's the game.
- [Jewell] Yeah, you're gonna
do whatever you want.
I think the one thing that
I always tells guys is like,
and I mean this, some
things are just true in life.
I think boys and girls
have to live life differently.
I think guys are impatient.
I wish guys knew that
at 40, you can be in the game
as much as 26.
You know, it's like,
it's a real mistake.
All these guys that
wanna hook up with chicks
don't realize they
should eat shit for seven years.
They'll do way better
at 33 than they will at 26
and have a fuck
load more leverage
for this
magical thing they want.
They're just posing
and getting sniffed out,
versus actually having it.
- [Jewell] I gotcha. So, yeah,
I totally
resonate with eat shit.
That was great.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- [Jewell] I guess one of the
struggles for me, obviously,
I'm starting this blog space.
So what I'm doing
currently in my career field,
I don't know if it's necessarily
in tune directly with like
something that's
gonna drive me for 20 years.
- It's definitely not.
- [Jewell] I don't
think it has to.
You already know it's not,
but that's okay.
There's a eat shit for that too.
If it's paying your bills
and giving you the air cover
to play a little
bit on its left hand,
the jab is very important.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Oh, the jab and the job.
I gotta do something with that.
Yeah, I love, you know.
hey finally, in
Crush It! my favorite
thing that I
established that I
wanna triple down on
is the 7 P.M. to
two in the morning.
I like the nine to five.
- [Jewell] Right.
- One of the things
I want people to do
is get more strategic
with their nine to five.
I would argue.
- [Jewell] That's exactly,
that's where I was going.
So right now in that space,
the job that I have,
I don't think it's
necessarily long term,
but there's
value in what I'm doing
that I can pick up
that maybe will help me
when I make that next move.
- And now the question becomes
Is there something
else that you can do
that pays you $10,000
less that's even more valuable
to where you think you're going.
- [Jewell] Gotcha.
So if you truly think
you're gonna be a personality,
if you truly believe that,
- [Jewell] I think I could.
- Do you think you want to?
I think people are
scared to say they want to
because of the vanity behind it.
I'm trying to make you feel safe
because I'm gonna
give you very, very good
piece of advice.
You just need to
feel safe with me.
- [Jewell] I think
I'm safe with it
and there's a lot of people
that tell me all the time.
Like, oh my goodness,
you have a presence,
you can do this .
- Well, you do.
You've got the
looks and the vibe,
you could.
- [Jewell] Yeah, I mean
I think it's something I--
- Well, this is
where I would say
you should go to L.A.
and make $15,000 less a year.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
'Cause you'll
stumble into more of it.
- [Jewell] Right, there's
more opportunities in L.A.
Okay. That makes sense.
Absolutely.
- It's also the
time to take risks.
- [Jewell] Yeah, I could fail
it now and rebound.
- You can do everything
wrong for the next five years
and be a ridiculously young man.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
Like you could do nothing
productive for five years
and still be early in the game.
- [Jewell] I got you.
- That's crazy.
Like, I wish
kids understood that.
- [Jewell] Mhmmm.
Yeah.
That's true.
And I love the
space that you operate in.
I think I'm very similar with
the contradiction of like,
I don't care what
anyone thinks about me
but at the same time
I want everyone to like me.
- You care.
I've got the same thing.
- [Jewell] So I guess--
- That's a
really good place to be.
I actually probably feel like
that's why I
probably like you intuitively.
That's the best place.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- The genuine,
I Don't Give A Fuck,
for real.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- And oh my God, like,
@sallypants44 in Ireland
with three
followers says you're a jerk.
I'm like fuck,
Sally Pants, no I'm not.
But that's incredible.
That's an
incredible paradox that is,
that I'm fascinated by
and almost wish on everybody
because then you're cruising.
Because really, then
you've got two gears.
I can turn on feeding
trolls when I want to,
I can turn on...
It's unbelievable.
I can turn it on
and off at any moment.
- [Jewell] Right.
- Just depending on
mood I'm in at that moment,
I can feed you and go deploy
being the bigger person like,
I'm so sorry you feel that way.
I hope we get to meet.
I do that all the time,
and other times I could say,
cool, you think I'm a dick.
I had one on Super Bowl night
where the guy's like,
and he's a great kid.
I DM'ed a bunch of them.
I love 'em.
Him and his bro.
But he was like, fuck you, Gary.
Tom Brady's 10 times,
100,000 times the man you are.
And I'm like, cool, cool.
Let's shelf that.
The problem is
Brady's a good dude too,
because he was just an athlete.
I could have won that,
but I'm like fuck,
Brady's a good dude.
So I was like cool,
let's shelf that for a minute.
What about me versus you?
Like, I'm willing
to pull either move.
- [Jewell] Right.
- That's a great place to be.
- I enjoy it.
I'm learning how to navigate
that, but--
- Yeah, it took me
a little while too.
- [Jewell] And I think that
that's probably
another reason why
I really connect with your
give, give, give, give, give.
- It's leverage.
- [Jewell] Never take if
you never have to.
- My great hope in life is
I never call in a favor.
- [Jewell] Yeah,
and so on that note,
I love to give.
I'm the same way
and so I can create
personal relationships
very quickly with anybody.
Joe Schmoe on the street,
give, give, give.
One thing that I struggle with
and maybe I'm looking
at this the wrong way is
taking the ability to create
those personal relationships
and develop
business out of them.
- Well, I think you
don't sell against it.
I think the thing
that I'd done different
than what people think I'm doing
or people that
they compare me to
is that I'm not
selling the audience.
- [Jewell] Right.
Yes, I've got a
book every three years.
Yes, I've got some
t-shirts here and there,
but there's
nothing meaningful there.
All the revenue I make
and those things combined
aren't as exciting as
what I do here in four minutes.
- [Jewell] Right.
And people don't get that.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
So what I would say is
you've got to create a
container to make money in
that isn't reliant
on being charismatic
and manipulating that
person into selling them
some horse shit.
- [Jewell] True.
- That's been the
great difference of me.
There is no $5,000 course.
There's not.
- [Jewell] Give it all
away for free.
- I do.
And yes, again,
but what has that done?
It's made me popular,
which has led to me
being a headline biller
for a speaking.
It led to me doing TV shows.
It's led to me being awareness
around the container
I created for the agency.
People go to
the Wine Library to visit
'cause that's like the
Mecca of where I started.
Every day there's
somebody on social media
taking a selfie
at the Wine Library.
The house that GaryVee built.
And you know,
if they buy $400 worth of wine.
I guess I make
17 cents at the end.
Like, you know, like
to me,
this is where you separate it.
What I would recommend
is figure out a container
that you can put it into
that isn't reliant on that,
and there's a way
to do it without being
a good business person.
So what I was gifted with,
the thing that people forget
and this is a big
thing people forget.
Is I didn't say a fucking word.
Zero, zero self promotion.
Zero narcissism.
For 14 years.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- And that's the
beginning of my official career.
It was even longer than that.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It was the triple reverse.
I was a kid,
not complaining
that I worked every day.
From 14 to 22
and then from
22 to basically 35,
2,000 what? Nine?
You know, fucking didn't talk.
I didn't talk.
- [Jewell] Just worked.
- I worked.
I gave myself
permission to talk.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- You know and
whether people think that
that's right or wrong,
meaning like today,
that's fine,
that will work itself out,
but I was a good
businessman first.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- Like this plaque
represents 22-year-old kid
building a 60 million
dollar business in a retail
environment, selling
beer, liquor and wine.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- That has nothing to
do with like, you know,
people everyday, what
has this guy ever done?
I'm like are you
so, I'm like how.
Now the reason I
don't get upset is,
I don't have the ego
to think that they should
have done the homework.
- [Jewell] Right.
- Like who am I?
Why should they do
the homework on my life?
They saw an Instagram video,
like, it's okay, and
by the way, my energy
does look on first sniff,
like some of the bad stuff.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- So I'm okay with that.
Here's what I'd say.
You got two moves.
One, you're either a
good enough businessman
where you've got
an architecture firm
that makes
$3 million dollars a year
and on the side, I mean,
you know like right now,
GaryVee, matches my business.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- But it didn't
when I was doing wine.
- [Jewell] Right.
- All that stuff that
happened with Crush It!
and all my
business advice, yeah, okay,
occasionally somebody
wanted to buy wine from me,
'cause they felt
good, but I wasn't,
it wasn't a natural flow,
and it isn't here either.
This company only sells
to Fortune 500 companies,
who probably look
negatively at the hype stuff.
- [Jewell] Right.
- So this is where
people are confused.
I have two
separate things going on.
You can do that, or you
can play it the other way,
which I think
is a very smart way
which is what I would be doing
if I wasn't a good businessman,
which is you can eat shit
building personal brand,
and instead of
monetizing the audience,
you monetize
through a third party
that has the
audience's attention.
What do I mean by that?
I mean you produce,
you produce, you produce,
and then a third party
conference wants to pay you
$5,000 to speak, and so
you're not selling directly
to the audience, but
you're in the B2B business
versus the B2C.
I'm in the B2B business.
- [Jewell] Yeah,
absolutely.
- My popularity is being
executed in a B2B environment.
I'm doing that with
Apple, for the show.
I'm doing that with these
conferences for the events.
I'm doing that in those ways.
I'm not doing it
direct to consumer.
I'm leading economics
'cause I could do it
direct to consumer.
- [Jewell] Yeah. Mhmmm.
- I'm leaving
50 cents on the dollar
and giving it to there,
but it creates such a better
relationship with the people.
I'm willing to leave
so much money on the table
to have you feel
about me the way you do.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
It makes 100% sense.
- 'Cause I'm
doing the long game.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Because all those
people making lots of money
on their ebook or this and that,
they're becoming
rich for the short term,
and I'm looking to become
wealthy for the long term.
So if you build
and build and build,
how you turn it into
something is you start getting
180,000 people
following you in Instagram,
or Snapchat, or the next
platform, and they really care,
there's gonna be businesses
that find you and figure out
how to make that move.
- [Jewell] Yep,
absolutely, I mean it's --
- And that's
where you should go.
You should do what I do.
You should go in biz dev
and use your charisma
with the biggest
brands in the world.
Go to conferences
where they are.
Try to reach out to them.
Look at everybody's
profile and be like,
oh, that's the CMO
of Kangaroo Sneakers.
Hey, Rick,
thanks for following me.
Can we get a drink?
- [Jewell] Mhmmm. Yeah.
- I do that with people,
like yesterday I saw
Malcolm Jamal Warner, you know,
Theo Huxtable, like said
something good about my car,
I DM'd him, like hey,
you know like biz sev,
for what you're doing,
it's easy to monetize
against your audience
in the short term.
Everybody's doing it.
It's why it will continue
to go down in value.
- [Jewell] Exactly.
So with that being
said, so, obviously,
you started
business side,
so me, I'm not
necessarily starting--
- [Gary] Good, and that's
great self-awareness.
You don't have to.
- But I also, you know,
I've heard you say, you know,
go all in on what
your strengths are,
but be dangerous in the
fields that you don't, so --
- [Gary] Yes.
- So don't be naive
and think that you don't
have to know a little
bit about this or that.
- It's nice.
- [Jewell] So
with that being said,
because I have that pickup--
- You know what I
would do if I were you?
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Like I already, like
I think I figured it out.
At least I feel really good
about this piece of advice,
and you know I'm not
usually this definitive.
I think you should
go work for somebody
that you wanna become like.
I think you should
so some real homework,
and look at who
looks more like you.
Okay, this one, like map 'em.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Then you
should go work for them.
- [Jewell] 'Kay.
- And get to as
close to them as possible.
- [Jewell] That's the
biggest opportunity to learn.
- And that's where
you go and be an admin.
I being serious.
- [Jewell] Yep, okay.
Well it makes sense.
- You see where I'm goin'?
- Yeah, because --
- [Gary] Does anybody
stand out, like when you look
at their careers?
Have you done that work yet?
- Not necessarily.
This is a kind of new
space and so I just,
the reason I'm
talking about the blog is
because it's been something
that's kind of in my head
for maybe the last six
say months or something,
and it's kind of been that
thing that's just in the back,
I'm like oh, I'll get to it,
and so this year,
the second week of
January or something
I put it on my Facebook,
I put it on and I say, hey --
- [Gary] You put
yourself out there.
- [Jewell] I put
myself out there.
- Smart. Suffocate yourself.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
So I could hold
myself accountable
and get into action,
and so with that,
I'm learning a lot more and
reaching out to different people
on running blogs, getting,
you know, traction with that
and just
different types of content,
that I think are valuable to me,
and which I think will
be valuable to other people.
- I think that's it,
like as long as it's valuable
to you, and as long
as it's true, don't judge
the content for the market.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- The market will decide.
- They just will decide.
It might not come.
Most people stink,
and aren't interested,
and can't pull it off.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- But overthinking it
upfront is wrong too.
All the breakthroughs
come when, you know,
like, otherwise there
would be no pioneering.
Otherwise,
there'd be no new genres.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Otherwise
everything would be the same.
There's always something new.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- And the only way to
win is if it's your truth.
- [Jewell] Right.
So in order to
avoid the shotgun approach
and just like, hey let me
reach out like and laser --
- [Gary] I don't think so.
- Like...
- [Gary] I'm okay with that.
I think whatever comes natural.
Here's what I would say.
It's more binary than that.
Produce.
- [Jewell] Just put it out
there --
- I think your logic,
I'm not gonna give you
a framework or a blueprint
that's that detailed.
- [Jewell] Yeah. Well, yeah.
- It's macro.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It's making the switch.
It's the bigger
thing that I've been poking
at periodically
through this conversation.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Give yourself
permission to be willing
to be a personality,
even though you think
it's a little douchey
and a little less logical,
and has some baggage,
and once you own it,
well then you're on
your way, because right now
you're half pregnant.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
You want it, but
you're not ready to go there,
and boy do I get it because,
again, I'm so comfortable
in my skin, and this took time.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- And I knew this
was the right move.
I knew documenting
everyday was the right move,
but I was like, whew.
Actually, you
and I were together
like the third day I did it.
- Oh we were?
- [Gary] Yep!
- [DRock] Remember that episode.
- [Gary] In Vegas.
- [Erik] Oh, that's right, yes!
- That's where I
was still trying.
I was like this is so weird.
Now it's like so normal.
(laughter)
I don't even know he's here.
- [Jewell] Exactly.
- It's crazy.
It's crazy.
Like it makes me really
understand why reality TV works.
Like humans get really
accustomed to their environment.
- Yeah, and I think
documenting yourself,
one thing that I struggle with
that frustrates
the hell out of me
is I know it's a talent,
I know it's something
that some people are born
with and some people aren't
but something will happen
in my day-to-day life,
that like the light bulb won't
click for like three hours
after or two weeks later,
I'm like oh shit,
I missed that by being
able to like really perceive
my own thoughts in the moment.
I think that's something
that you're really good at.
You're like, oh shit,
okay, let's go act on that.
- [Gary] I do.
- Do you think there's
any way to like hone that in,
to like really develop that?
- Probably.
I don't know how.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
I mean, I know
documenting for me,
like going back
and watching things,
like that day that
I recorded, I'm like,
oh damn, okay I can change--
- Interesting, that's cool.
Yeah, it comes
so intuitive to me.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- I mean I would make the most
drastic decision on a whim
that you could ever imagine.
- [Jewell] Yeah,
'cause you can rebuild.
- Yeah.
'Cause I'm not scared.
- [Jewell] I think
that's the biggest thing.
- I'm not scared.
- [Jewell] For a
lot of people.
I mean, I'm not
scared but I'm scared.
I don't have the VaynerMedia--
- Yeah, but I had
it the whole time.
I think it's a DNA thing.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Every time
somebody goes, but this...
I'm like, no, no, no.
I was here.
Like, where do you think I was?
- [Jewell] More, more, more.
- Like you know,
more, more, more.
Did you see Drake?
- [Jewell] I saw,
I saw that (laughs).
- I don't think it's true,
but it's surely wild.
That was wild.
- [Jewell] Gained
a lot of traction.
- No, I still can't
wrap my head around it.
I just don't see the
path of how that hit his radar
so quickly and I don't
have that direct link,
but you never know.
- [Jewell] I think you're
bigger than you think though.
- No, I feel good in my reach.
It just newish, too.
It happened too fast.
Trust me, if I
pushed it hard for
three, four or five
months, and then it happened,
I would have been, like, yeah!
Just seemed like it
happened way too fast.
But maybe, I don't know.
- [Jewell] A couple weeks,
a week, what?
- Yeah.
- [Jewell] How long?
- It's really, what
do you think DRock?
No, no, what do you think?
You think it's got a chance?
I feel like the only
chance is one of his boys
is following--
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Said it,
he picked up, (fingers snap)
That's the path.
- [Jewell] That's the millenial
space that you operate in.
- Exactly right, no, that I
believe potentially is true.
Without even one knowing.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It was funny. Okay.
- So, yeah, alright, well I mean
it seems like I just
need to stop being a pussy
and just get after it (laughs).
- [Gary] I think so man,
here's what I would say,
so you know what's cool?
I can give this advice 'cause
I don't have it in business,
but I have it in other places.
I didn't learn how to swim
until I was nine years old.
And the only
reason I learned to swim
was my six year old sister.
I was playing Knock
Hockey at the pool club,
and I heard from a distance,
that my mom was
cheering (hands clap)
my sister had
just learn how to swim.
Before she was
finished clapping,
I had my shirt off,
jumped in, and started swimming
because I didn't want
the historical narrative
to be that my sister
learned how to swim before me.
- [Jewell] So competitive.
- So competitive.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Jumping off that cliff
in Jamaica on spring break,
I'm scared of heights
and things like that, right?
That's what it takes,
it takes just
jumping in the pool,
and then the second you do it,
it's your first kiss,
it's everything, it's that.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
You're just gonna have to do it.
And I think the
best way to do it is
a similar version of how you
called yourself out on social,
but a more
extreme version, which is,
go map who you want to be like,
email them cold,
and their inner circle,
until one of them says,
sure, you can come work
for me for free as my
admin or my chief of staff,
and move to L.A. and do it.
- [Jewell] Makes sense.
- It will work.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Here's why,
you can always go back
to what you're
doing now in 24 months.
The practical world
is always open armed.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It's what the
whole thing is built for.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- That's what people don't get.
The practical world?
The way school is built,
to be an employee?
They're waiting for you always.
They're always there for you.
- [Jewell] Mhmmm.
- To me, that's
how I see the world.
It's actually a
no risk game.
It doesn't go away.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It's always there.
- [DRock] I also think
the narrative of DailyVee
is interesting too, because
we didn't start daily.
We started three times,
two times a week,
where we just were
trying to figure it out.
- I iterate a lot.
People think I figure--
I figure out macros,--
- [DRock] Yep.
- and then it takes sometimes
years to get to the micro.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- [DRock] Yep.
- [Jewell] I
think that's exactly it.
I try and micro
it out before I--
- [Gary] Everybody does.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] that's why
I'm successful.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Success is predicated
on pushing as high as you can,
and then working backwards.
Everybody else tries to go up.
- [Jewell] Yeah. Well
that's--
- You know?
I wonder when I
realized how strategic
the narrative of
buying the Jets was?
- [Jewell] Hmm.
- You know?
That's just my disguise for
being obsessed with the journey.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- I wish it never ended.
The reason I don't want to
die and talk about my funeral
has nothing to do
with anything other than
I'm in complete bliss.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- I'm doin' it.
I'm doin' it my way,
the way I was built to do,
and it's clean.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- And everything
else is secondary.
The followers,
the money, the attention,
they're all such a
distant secondary to that space.
That pure space of doing
exactly what you want to do
every second of your life,
the way you wanted to do it.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
Which is why I
struggled so much with school.
It was the complete reverse.
It was rules
and structure around
something I couldn't believe in.
And that's why I feel so
much pain for the masses.
Because I feel like
that's everybody's job.
- [Jewell] There's a lot of
drones out there, unfortunately.
They just don't know
how to break out of that
and I think that's why,
I think the blog
space is going to be
big for me because
it does play on my
coaching and leadership
for my little brothers
and really taking that,--
- [Gary] As long as you stay
in your lane, you will win.
Stay in that lane.
Make those analogies.
I'm able to break
out of my lane because
I make analogies
of things of how,
the reason people throw
me in to the motivation,
I'm talking about life,
though the lens of business.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
It's why my parenting
advice goes so far,
that's why I'm
writing Perfectly Parented.
'Cause it's operations--
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It's reverse engineering
a human being.
It's all that stuff.
It's people's behavior.
I understand it.
- [Jewell] Right.
- That's why this
is easy for me.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
I know I'm right.
- [Jewell] Mhmmm, yeah.
I know you're
right, too (laughs).
- And so I think the reason
people are attracted to me
is there's a little bit of that
immigrant, Jersey, street thing
that everybody gets
value in different ways.
Some people need a little
bit of an East-coast push,
that's my natural
way of communicating
and that works for some people.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- That's why it works for,
a lot of young guys love me,
'cause it works for them.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- They can associate.
Middle America grandmas,
not as much.
The f-bomb is a binary turn-off.
- [Jewell] It's so funny
how many people are like,
oh but he...
I'm like you
don't even understand,
get past the f-bomb--
- But you have to understand,
the cursing's really
fun for me because
if one is inable
to get through cursing
to get to the message,
they have no shot
of listening to my advice.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It's almost another
subconscious mechanism
to not let people in.
I actually think
my whole life is that.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
I think I act in a way that vets
people before they get to me.
It's not even for me,
you know what's so funny?
I don't need anybody.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- It's that there's no chance
they're gonna get
value out of me,
people that are
actually attracted to me
struggle with the
macro-nature of my message.
If you're stopping at cursing,
you've got no prayer.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
You're stopping at fucking,
the first floor,
I'm trying to get you
to the 72nd penthouse.
The people that
like me get to 55,
but getting 55 to
72 is a lot of work.
If you're stopping at floor one,
I'm not getting you there.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- If you're literally
scared because of cursing,
in today's world, that's
what you're gonna like,
that's what's stopping you from
hearing the
purity of the message?
Like, you're literally
getting ripped off by
people that are
selling you stuff
garbage, garbage
because they don't curse,
and I'm out of consideration
because of my cursing,
you are a fucking loser.
- [Jewell] Yeah, I absolutely
agree, I tell people (mumbles)
you guys don't understand.
And you've effectively
become a mentor to me,
you got that mentor
video out and everybody's like,
oh, you won't be my--
you are a mentor, I
watch you and I soak it in.
- The mentor
video was another proxy.
- People aren't looking, like,
it's the Wizard of Oz.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- They take everything literal.
I do everything
to weed people out.
- [Jewell] Mhmmm.
- To judge people.
That's how I
scale big businesses.
All my rules
and all my structure
is to actually know who you are.
When you leave a comment
that like I'm
wrong about mentorship,
it gives me an insight to how
you're thinking about things
'cause you actually
didn't hear me in that video,
which is an insight into
where your mind is right now.
- [Jewell] Right.
- That video
wasn't about mentorship.
That video was about, go do.
That video was more, more, more.
You have to execute.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- If you keep wanting a mentor,
and a book, and a course,
you're just in the
game of the learning.
The learning is safe to you.
You're paying for safety.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- These people are
piranhas on your safety needs.
I want you out.
- [Jewell] And I think that's--
- Like, these people
want more followers
and want people to
stay, I want everybody out.
I want to have 4,000,000
followers and zero engagement.
- [Jewell] Mhmmm.
That's the reverse.
- [Jewell] It's so
funny because
you've done that
exact thing to me.
So I was very much
learn, learn, learn, perfect.
And like after
watching you, I got...
It's a transition,
I'm growing out of it,
but it's funny how
I take action faster.
- [Gary] I'm pushing you.
I'm pushing you.
- [Jewell] That's why I said
you're like a real mentor.
- The reason people
leave a struggle with me
is I'm making
them uncomfortable.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- They're struggling because,
I'm exposing its truth.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- And everybody else is,
like,
they genuinely don't like me,
pushing them for
free to their truth.
They'd rather pay somebody to
reinforce their shortcomings.
I mean it's insane.
- [Jewell] You can't do
anything in the comfort zone.
- But here's why I do it.
The legacy.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Nobody goes to
those people and say,
"Thank you for
what you did for me."
They go to those
people 23 years later and say,
"You fucked me pretty good."
- [Jewell] Yep.
- You got me.
- [Jewell] Your whole
legacy is gonna be predicated
on how many other GaryVees--
- A hundred thousand,
and when you factor that,
do you know that
your grandchildren
are gonna watch this video?
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Do you understand they're
gonna be kids when I'm dead,
for thirty years,
that are gonna watch this,
who love you,
who you're their grandfather.
And they're gonna be like,
that
that was when,
like,
could you imagine?
Could you imagine if
there was video right now
of this nature
of some iconic
individual, or even,
iconic in your own family?
Like that person that made it?
I couldn't imagine
watching videos of my dad
sitting in a room
being in America for one
year with a heavy accent,
getting good advice.
Like, that's insane.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- That's, that's
very attractive to me.
- [Jewell] With like,
you know, Instagram stories
and Snapchat stories,
and things like that,
because I'm putting
more and more stuff out,
everyday I make it a point to
save it, and I'm storing it.
- [Gary] Yep.
- So that like, later
on I can go back and look.
And even a week later, I'm like,
"Damn, that happened last week?
I forgot about that piece."
But, you know it's
instant frame of mind.
- I was watching the Grammys
last night and these tributes,
and I'm like,
that's what I'm drawn to.
I'm like, I want tributes.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- I just do.
And like, fine.
You can be mad
at me for that, but
I find it amazing.
I feel like people
who are really obsessed
with their legacy
give the world the most.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Because that's
their selfishness.
Post-game.
Everybody else
is trying to take.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
That makes so much sense.
- Go find who you
think you're like.
Go do some real homework.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Find the person that's, you
know I'm not that exact thing.
Find that balance of
charisma, practicality.
Try to figure out who that is,
and then go work for them.
That is the best piece of
advice I could give anybody.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Go work for the
person you think you are.
- [Jewell] Yep.
- 'Cause,
hence, their success,
you know.
The successful version of you.
- [Jewell] Right.
- Because if you map
with that person 80%,
like DRock and I
map philosophically.
It's not like we
have the same skills,
but we're the same kind of
dude in our heart.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- So that helps.
So like,
watching him
evolve in 24 months,
there was no filmmaker
that was gonna teach him that.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Maybe there is, but
do you know what I mean?
And by the way, if
there is that filmmaker
with that EQ mapping, that
would have been the person.
- [Jewell] Mhmmm.
- But,
it helps.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
It makes a whole lot of sense.
I'm gonna have
to do my homework.
- Do your homework.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
I'll have to keep
you updated on that.
- Please.
- [Jewell] I'm also,
I'm late to this
party but I'm jumping in
the 2017 challenge.
- [Gary] You are?
- Yeah, so.
- [Gary] Well by the way,
that's interesting to me because
you know, you didn't come across
as hardcore, like selling,
because we didn't
go down that path.
To me, the biggest reason
I love the 2017 Flip Challenge
is because
teaching people how to,
you know that whole, like,
you can bring them to the,--
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- You teach people how to sell,
you unlock a
totally different thing.
- [Jewell] Right.
Yeah, no, I'm excited about it.
- I can't wait for
this spring and summer,
when everybody's garage-saling,
and flea-marketing.
- Oh yeah.
- I can't wait to, my
weekends are gonna be so fun
with people like,
sending out details of like.
By the way, it's
been such a selfish thing.
People posting,
"I bought this t-shirt
"at the thrift
store for a dollar.
"I sold it for $9.99."
That high, of the flip,
even not even my money
is the greatest.
- [Jewell] Right, you're
creating business people.
- It's not even that,
I love the flip.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- The action.
- [Jewell] Yeah, right.
- Yeah, I'm like, "Oh my God,
"you bought a Smurf
figure for 40 cents,
"and it's nine bucks?"
I just get off on the flip.
It's not even like,
that one's not as noble.
That's just a short term
action of the flip.
(dramatic music)